thousands of opposition activists have
come from different parts of the capital
and the country to this rally they want
the government to go
this illegitimate government has
destroyed democracy in Bangladesh and
the people want restoration of democracy
which is why they have taken to the
streets and protest
this road March come just a week after a
major rally in the capital protesters
also want opposition leader and former
prime minister khalidazier to be
released along with all other political
prisoners
tens of thousands of people
for a road
capital
they have only one demand the
resignation of the government and to
have an election under a caretaker
interim government Rights group have
criticized the government for cracking
down on its critics since 2022 at least
12 people have been shot dead by police
hundreds injured and thousands of
opposition members arrested popular
social media influencer hero Alum ran as
an independent candidate for a vacant
Parliament sit in the capitals affluent
area on Monday he was attacked by ruling
party supporters causing outrage across
the country
I have come a long way to show my
solidarity I want the right to vote and
cost my vote to whomever that I please
in recent month the U.S the U.N and
European Union have all expressed
concern about human rights and political
freedoms in Bangladesh but government
rejects any demand for an election time
caretaker government election during the
election according to the Constitution
the law enforcement agencies will be
under the election commissioner and they
will only operate under his Direction
many people are also angry at the
government for failing to stop soaring
energy and food prices
we don't feel the general election under
this government is going to be free and
secured we want the immediate formation
of a neutral caretaker government under
which the next election should take
place
with a troubled economy and soaring cost
of living Bangladesh now faces the
additional challenge of growing unrest
and calls for a change of government
ahead of the next general elections can
we chaudry Al Jazeera Dhaka thank you